citizens of the reject nation greg here
johnny john how you feeling bud i am
wide awake and ready to go let's do this
we got ourselves an official clip for
she-hulk a show john has always believed
in i have since the get-go i'm excited
i'm very excited for the show love the
last trailer love the featurette that we
got as well the more we see of this the
more i'm enjoying it and we got like a
minute clip here so let's hop into it
but before we do i'm gonna ask you guys
kindly hulk smash that like button
doesn't take too much effort so put the
effort in don't be lazy all right guys
we will be reacting to the show so do
keep a lookout for when those reactions
come out let's get to it
[Music]
being a hulk asks for balance
okay
that makes sense
look at the yoga
[Music]
wow
cut out the middle finger part i'm
clearly nailing it at all these things
when am i ever going to use this as a
lawyer jen when you have powers like
this it's like putting a target on your
back in the backs of all the people you
care about oh cool yet another way my
life is grown thanks bruce all right all
i've been doing is showing you the
downsides of being a hulk but there are
a few upsides
let's do it our bodies metabolize
alcohol at an incredibly fast rate i
kept which means that we can drink so
much and not get drunk
no
that's good
the hulk's an alcoholic alcohol click oh
very nicely done there johnny very
nicely done what do you think uh very
charming clip you know i mean i'm one of
the most appealing things about the show
is uh seeing how bruce and jennifer
walters will interact with each other i
mean this was a slight clip but even
just from this little glimpse i feel
like they have a lot of chemistry and
i'm excited to see how that unfolds into
the rest of the show and how the show
itself carries on this theme of the
upsides and the downsides of being a
hulk are you excited to see those
comments come in if people being like
can't believe they made she-hulk
stronger than hulk yes that's what i'm
anticipating the most because you know
clearly if you look at the two of them
in these images i mean she's physically
smaller than him so that's ridiculous
and impossible well you know i could see
those comments definitely coming in
already this actually gives us a good
insight into the kind of character art
that she's going to be having here i
mean trying to live you know both the
personal life have the career as being a
lawyer while trying to also
simultaneously balance it with being uh
you know a character with superhuman
abilities now like should she also be a
superhero while also trying to be a
protector of people follow this legal
law path as well you know there's some
stuff with the cgi that still looks a
little bit off to me but maybe it'll be
improved by the time it comes out at the
same time though i was thinking about it
that because of the kind of tone the
show seems to be aiming for that kind of
tone the show seems to be striking cgi i
think it's not really as big of a deal
to me as it was when i first thought and
only because like it feels like it's
supposed to be at times like a little
bit goofy and a little bit silly and
then perhaps the cgi should really like
click and be dynamic when it really
counts that's what i imagine that
they're actually going to be going for
and am enjoying seeing that mark ruffalo
is looks like he's going to be a
prevailing part of this journey but i do
kind of want down the road for them
hopefully to go back to a little bit
more of the rageful imposing hulk you
know it was kind of interesting looking
back yet because at silent monaco do the
incredible hulk reaction and watching it
back and like we've come a long way yes
ever since that thor ragnarok we have
made that hulk way funnier yeah
hey i mean he's just pretty much a
sentient guy now he's like totally well
adjusted really funny and being a hulk
has really a few downsides any longer i
wonder if they'll do anything to maybe
set us up for bruce banner be able to
now shift in between
being human bruce banner with gray hairs
we saw in the shang qi trailer you know
go into professor hulk mode you know be
who we see here in this trailer because
yeah i mean i like the idea of seeing
some more of the fun hulk and seeing
some more the upsides of being a hulk
because that's what i feel like you know
avengers end game really gave us where
he was able to mesh best of the both
worlds together now getting to see some
of the more partying fun side and
perhaps practicing some of that balance
and
yoga training because it's like hulk had
the rage problems and she-hulk seems
like she's
frustrated
she's just annoying
yeah just kind of bummed by the
circumstances yeah it does make me
wonder about like the conflict because
we're obviously gonna at least see the
origin of you know her getting this
blood transfusion the effects of
immediately realizing what is changing
within her and i wonder you know like
they've given us like kind of precious
little of that we've seen so much of
them training together so many of these
you know kind of situations that are
played for whimsy because she is so well
adjusted to them and yeah it makes me
wonder if a for jennifer walters if
there will be any kind of adverse effect
aside from the mental personal struggle
with it but also will this maybe spell
something for bruce that adds to maybe a
conflict for his character or something
to give us uh you know like a thread
moving forward as to where he might go
or as to how he might evolve because
what i'm getting from these trailers
it's obviously like a really fun
prospect to get the two of them together
but part of me wonders if we'll only see
bruce a lot in the first chunk of the
show when they're you know in mexico
doing this training and stuff like that
before she really kind of has the
balance about how to you know go about
being the lawyer being she-hulk at the
same time i like that they're leading
with it but i also feel like it might be
a bit of a mislead in that i don't think
that necessarily the whole show is just
going to be like them chumming around
yeah uh but even so yeah i feel like
they could introduce a some interesting
you know characters themes for jennifer
but also yeah some kind of kick-off
point for where we could see bruce go
next and maybe that will have some uh
greater sense of peril or sense of
struggle or sense of i don't know
anguish of some kind because yeah like
professor hulk is such a well-adjusted
character by now and not that that's a
bad thing but also too if you look back
past the mcu it's like you have the ed
norton movie and you have all the
different mark ruffalo appearances but
he hasn't had his own solo hulk venture
and i feel like at some point down the
line it would still be kind of good to
get that and i feel like if you're gonna
do that you still need some element of
the beast within that's hard to control
so yeah it makes me wonder about the
whole thing but as it stands i really do
like the both of them together and i
love you know the anticipation of seeing
how that's going to unfold and i hope
there's more to that than the trailers
are giving us so far all right well
she-hulk we have arrived here what did
you guys think of this clip are you
excited for the show leave your thoughts
down below you guys can subscribe click
that bell leave a like and also we got
some patrons to shout out walkie talkie
hey ashante the conclusion is primal
evolution i'm rhymin with ian simon frog
frog frog frog songhai glover is too old
for this [ __ ] it's never too soon to
shout out jacob neptune it's just you
and me nmb
run from the cops fan pops alan ling
that's the thing logan burton
39 not on my i'm kusi kusi
brucey brucey don't stare at the bear in
the garage nick x
yeah i shouldn't even be in this video
you're for adults juan longoria yeah
yeah how are you gail ferguson
ferguson rhyme you're gonna be impressed
muhammad i'll show ronnie
i
right on the money
jaron winer
browse we've already warner bros you're
a warner bro biff the cliff rodriguez
master
tonsils thank you to you guys for
joining our patreon page you'll be
getting shout out again this month
because uh yeah this counts for july
don't worry we we know the math we know
it's all up here don't yell at us we
know the math you got it
all right
[Music]